when you start working I mean does your
mom mind that you start working as a kid
uh oh I started I started pretty young
but I didn't
um Freaks and Geeks was the beginning
yeah in a lot of ways but and you were
14 when that started 15 15. 15. and then
when we when we started going we started
on the series when I was 16 because I
had a car at that point oh okay it's
interesting starting in a business so
young yeah most people don't have
experience I guess working before they
graduate high school to that degree with
that level of responsibility I guess
which I was not ready for I proved that
in some ways in what ways
um there's one day where I fully slept
in and missed half a day of work for me
that was a huge life lesson but for
other people it's probably a reminder
that oh this this kid's just a child
yeah yeah like he's not ready to do to
like the the the timely nature of any
responsible adult getting to their job
on time I wasn't fully prepared for
and that was a good life lesson for me
yeah yeah I let a lot of people down I
just remember the disappointment in in
uh Jay Kasdan was genuinely really
pissed at me and he had every right to
be yeah but um yeah it was valuable for
me to to learn yeah a lesson that day
they almost cut me out of a big part of
the show because of that oh wow that
episode that uh that does suck when you
[ __ ] up and somebody just can't help
themselves but like they're pissed at
you and they let you know like I'm
really pissed at you because there's
part of you that's like come on we all
[ __ ] up every now and then right now I
feel that way now at the time I was like
in a turtle shell like scared shitless
of the way that people felt about me
because I was judging myself so harshly
I felt awful it's also a very unique
workplace for a child it's not that
you're not a bagger at the grocery store
you know there's a lot of the Reds on
you as a 15 or 16 year old kid yeah yeah
and at that point because I was 16 I was
responsible for taking myself to work
whereas most kids at that point your
parent or Guardian is dropping you off
right so there's a level of
responsibility that goes to them as well
well you were a minor did you need to
have somebody on set with you or did you
to get emancipated the teacher teacher
or the teacher would be yeah okay so
that counts as a guardian oh wow
um and so you were going you were having
to do school at the same time oh wow
suck I made it really fun but not for
the teacher I ran around a lot it was
not a healthy environment for learning I
think it was Philip
Phil was the I think that was the name
of the teacher yeah
um really sweet guy he drove like two
hours to get to work every day he used
to pee in a probably wouldn't like me
saying this but I remember him telling
me that he had to be sometimes in a
plastic bottle because he would he
didn't want to leave the freeway it
could cost him an extra 15 minutes so he
was just like I bring bottles I've done
that have you ever done that
um I don't think I've been forced to do
that just stuck in traffic on the 405
and really trying to avoid doing that
but then ending up having to
you know
pee in a bottle yeah you know and then
Chuck it at a hippie oh I I really I
heard the beginning of that word and I
thought you're gonna say and then chug
it and get it back in my system oh yeah
that's a thing with me that's one of my
things
that's actually a religion I'm starting
you ever watched Nathan For You uh-huh
that did you see the episode where uh
he's talking to a gas station a guy at
the gas station and he just goes off
into a thing that kids need to drink pee
no at the end he says uh you know one of
my secrets is I drink my grandchildren's
pizza oh that's right and that's that's
my secret of life is that I drink my
grandchildren's pee
and that was a trip I don't know how he
put that on the air yeah that guy was
that was a genuine you were seeing the
guy's face so that means he signed off
on it yeah he signed a release he did
not recognize that that was something
his family at the very least doesn't
want him talking about
absolutely I hope it's from a cup I hope
it's from a cup oh no not right from the
spout yeah please do not
oh dear
um well now
um
um when now Freaks and Geeks well the
first uh well the first thing I want to
say is like are you spoiled for the rest
of your career for being on something
that's so good I really felt that way
for a long time and I've been really
lucky to continue to have experiences
with really great
um creative minds and really talented
people on all sides of production
with um party down and uh a show I did
on Adult Swim with Paul Scheer called
ntsf sdsuv we had a really great group
of people and on Silicon Valley
um and I've been lucky to do a lot of
other things that have been really
rewarding and and
um but yeah for a while I was like this
sucks like like what a what a wonderful
start and then there was a real drought
after that too because I just didn't
know how to do it like when you when you
are handed something that's that
incredible
I don't think I really knew how to get
back there again I didn't realize how
high the mountain was that we landed on
that we were
um you know
that we were lucky enough to to all be a
part of this incredible
um project together but
yeah somehow it's it's all come back
around and I've I I lasted long enough
to make it back to do some pretty fun
things were you Typecast after that like
was it hard to get because it's such
like among the sort of you know I mean
it's it it television Works in
archetypes and I mean among the like the
Freaks and Geeks you're the Geeks and
like you were the guy with the glasses
and you were the skinny guy and like
when with the short hair yeah
um is that like a burden that you had to
then carry with you uh I I feel like
that's what I anticipated and to some
degree I did see that as a result of the
experience that we had on Freaks and
Geeks and and but it as you know somehow
I
I mean I I I've been lucky to I think
you could kind of Clump a lot of the
parts that I've played into a similar
category but but I I see them all as
quite different and unique so it's
for me it's been a really fun roller
coaster I'm playing yeah playing
different
a lot of different things
um but yeah it's fun I'd much rather
play someone with like heart and honesty
and integrity than like to play an
archetype yeah rather than an important
you know wisdom yeah yeah